an diesem wochenende hätten sie sich
treffen wollen
zum ersten mal seit 1200 jahren die
christlichen orthodoxen kirchen dieser
welt doch nun ist das paradoxe konzil in
letzter minute geplatzt wehrmacht
überhaupt die orthodoxie aus und was
bewegt die gläubigen welche themen
entstanden denn auf der konzils agenda
darüber habe ich mit stefan aus atanasio
gesprochen
er ist griechisch orthodoxe theologe und
lebt und arbeitet in bern
ich habe ihn zuerst gefragt woher die
enge verbindung von religion und politik
denn hier kommt beispielsweise in
russland
es sind bilder wie dieses ladin ihr
putin der russische präsident mit kirill
dem ersten dem oberhaupt der
russisch-orthodoxen kirche gemeinsam
diese enge verbindung von religion und
politik ist das typisch für die
orthodoxie wissen sie die orthodoxe
kirche ist wahrhaftig besonders heute
sehr stark mit den regionalen
politischen mächten sag ich jetzt mal
verbunden
im sinne besonders in den heimatländern
das heißt dass besonders in russland
oder in griechenland oder auch in
serbien in anderen orthodoxen ländern
die politik und die kirche sehr stark
zusammenarbeiten
das kommt natürlich aus den
nationalistischen sag ich jetzt mal
bewegungen des 19 jahrhunderts das so
sehr die religion also den orthodoxen
glauben mit der identität verbunden hat
wissen sie als das osmanische reich
aufgebrochen ist also wir gehen jetzt
sehr weit zurück natürlich aber ich
glaube dort ist die ursache des
nationalismus zu suchen als das
osmanische reich aufgebrochen ist
langsam gab es durch die französischen
ideen der französischen revolution ein
bestreben der verschiedenen nationen
eine eigenes eine eigene nation zu
entwickeln und eine eigene identität zu
propagieren und das sind die kirchen
jetzt auch eine chance sich zu
profilieren
das ist nicht selbstverständlich
in russland war ja ich sag mal
sozialismus gegen die religion
eingestellt dass sie jetzt eine große
blüte der religion wieder in russland
aber warum eigentlich diese verbindung
ich hab da auch so kritische untertöne
gegenüber diesem nationalismus
herausgehört ja wissen sie die orthodoxe
kirche versteht sich als eine kirche und
auch ökologisch und theologisch gesehen
ist sie auch eine kirche diese
nationalismen aber die besonders wie
gesagt im zwanzigsten jahrhundert und im
19ten sich entwickelt haben gibt uns den
anschein dass es eine spaltung in der
orthodoxen kirche geben könnte
beziehungsweise eine spaltung sich
anbahnt zwischen den verschiedenen
nationalen traditionen
hierbei ist besonders zu erwähnen der
streit der konflikt zwischen der
orthodoxen kirche in russland also dem
moskauer patriarchat und dem
ehrenoberhaupt der gesamten orthodoxen
kirche dem ökumenischen patriarchat von
konstantinopel
hier gibt es ein streit in bezug zu ja
eine verpflichtung des an rechtes könnte
ich sagen der ersten kirche der
orthodoxie dass die das ökumenische
patriarchat ist und der kirche moskau
die natürlich das größte patriarchat ist
dass die summe der gläubigen und so
weiter angeht aber historisch historisch
doch erst viel viel später entstanden
ist als das ökumenische patriarchat von
konstantinopel
sie gehört dazu griechisch orthodoxen
tradition sind da aufgewachsen schauen
wir mal wo diese kirchen her kommen dass
sich jetzt treffen es sind ja 14 kirchen
die sich zu diesem paradoxen konzil
versammeln sie haben es erwähnt es sind
weltweit ungefähr 300 millionen unter
docs gläubige auf dieser karte
je stärker roth desto mehr orthodoxe
gläubige also ganz klar oder russland
dann die länder der ehemaligen
sowjetunion
ich denke gesicht bulgarien ukraine
weissrussland aber auch balkan
griechenland diese etwas weniger
schraffierten aber doch weltweit für den
verbreiteten orthodoxen ja sehen sie
eine sehr schöne karte wo man wirklich
das orthodoxe bild wieder sieht ich habe
am anfang erwähnt die orthodoxe kirche
versteht sich als eine kirche und und
das ist natürlich besonders wichtig was
die wolfsburger situation in der
orthodoxen kirche angeht also gläubiger
von armen ländern jetzt in sozialen
ausland leben genau wie sie zum beispiel
in deutschland zwar aufgewachsen bin
seit jahren in der schweiz oder russen
russin die gläubig sind daneben die
nordamerikaner leben
genau so ist es und sie haben ja erwähnt
es gibt 14 autofahrer oder bzw autonome
orthodoxe kirche mit jurisdiktion allen
vorrechten da kann auch keine eingreifen
sind sie sozusagen frei zu entscheiden
was sie machen möchten in ihrem
patriarchen beziehungsweise in ihren
jurisdictions gebieten und und dann gibt
es eben die diaspora situation die ja
die in keiner jurisdiktion zugeteilt ist
deshalb haben wir das phänomen was
eigentlich von psychologischer seite
nicht erlaubt ist dass in einer diözese
ich sag jetzt mal in der diözese der
schweiz mehrere orthodoxe bischöfe
wirken also einerseits der
griechisch-orthodoxe metropolit von
leben menschen aus diesen beiden der
inneren hier genau das ist eigentlich
eine situation die besonders mit der
einwanderung von orthodoxen gläubigen
nach westeuropa und in die westliche
welt insgesamt gefolgt ist und dann
natürlich die kirche nach gezogen ist
ist das thema auf diesem konzil die
diaspora situation ist ein thema auf dem
konzil und es wurde auch ein papier oder
soll ein papier verabschiedet werden
dass die
diaspora situation etwas lösen soll
das heißt es hat sich bewährt in den
vergangenen jahren dass sich die
verschiedenen orthodoxen bischöfe einer
region in einer orthodoxen synode
versammeln eine bischofssynode und dort
nach außen hin mit einer stimme sprechen
besonders gut funktioniert das in
deutschland oder auch in österreich wenn
es habe so ein konzil gab seit 1200
jahren nicht mehr jetzt habe ich
verstanden diese orthodoxen kirchen sind
sehr regional organisiert das mag
historische gründe an die seiten aber
auch schön miteinander
warum rufen sie die jetzt in 2016 zu
einem konzert zu sagen ja wissen sie die
idee eines konzils ist ja schon viel
viel früher als es gibt ja die idee
schon seit circa 100 jahren ein konzil
einzuberufen und das hat nie geklappt
nein und ich muss sagen es hat nicht
geklappt aus historischen gründen wissen
sie ich sage vor 100 jahren circa also
so 1801 1890 er jahren hat es angefangen
mit einer idee dass wir uns doch alle
versammeln sollen und dann besonders in
den 1920 er jahren hat sich das dann mit
einem ökumenischen patriarchen dann mehr
etabliert aber sie wissen so gesprächen
über eine zeitperiode wo es politisch
sehr heikel war also einerseits das
aufbrechen des osmanischen reiches und
wo die orthodoxen kirchen besonders
natürlich gewirkt kabinett kriegen dann
die weltkriege und dann der kalte krieg
und diesem kalten krieg ist eigentlich
diese gesamte spaltung sag ich jetzt mal
zwischen der russischen und der
griechischen welt zustande gekommen
die griechische welt und damit auch die
griechischen patriarch hatte er den
westen zugeneigt und natürlich die
slawischen patriarchates besonders also
russland dann dem osten beziehungsweise
dem ostblock sogenannten und das hat
natürlich eine politische spaltung und
eine trennlinie herbeigeführt auch
innerhalb der orthodoxen kirchen das
klingt wirklich nach einem historischen
erfolg dass das jetzt zu einem konzil
kommt
es findet auf kreta stadt nicht in
istanbul wismar geplant war auch
irgendein streit dahinter nein diesmal
kein streit beziehungsweise kein
kirchlicher streit sagen hier ist mal so
wie sie gesagt haben das konzil war ja
eigentlich geplant in konstantinopel
also istanbul in der irene kirche also
eine hier eine sehr historische kirche
wo schon mal ein ökumenisches konzil der
alten kirche stattgefunden hat aber
wegen der lage der politischen lage
zwischen russland und der türkei
besonders nach dem absturz des des
fliegers des russischen fliegers an der
türkischen grenze hat der
russisch-orthodoxe patriarch ja doch
gebeten dass man das konzil doch
verlegen sollte bzw irgendwo anders da
hinlegen sollte da er nicht bereit war
in die türkei zu fliegen beziehungsweise
das nicht konnte mit meinem sensation
ethnische spannungen dem abschuss seines
russischen kampfjets und daraufhin wurde
dass das konzil auf kreta verlegt aber
ich glaube es gibt schlimmere ordnung
ein konzil abzuhalten als kreta
was eint eigentlich die orthodoxen
kirchen die orthodoxen kirchen ich habe
schon gesagt jurist optional sind sie
sehr autonom dazu kirchenrechtlichen
auch kirchenrechtlich und da entscheiden
auch in den verschiedenen also 14
verschiedenen regionen auch auto
gefahren selbständige synoden über über
verschiedene pastorale entscheidungen in
dieser region das was ein und ist für
die orthodoxie ist die ihre liturgie
also die göttliche liturgie wie sie
heißt
der kelch die liturgie das abendmahl ist
das was die gesamte orthodoxie 1 das
heißt das wenn ich zum beispiel sams
erwähnt ich gehörte griechisch
orthodoxen tradition an
hier in bern wo ich auch ohne und nicht
bei den chris katholiken als assistent
an der patient wirke an der versierte
genau jene welt wären genau wenn ich
also nach bern in die kirche gehe ich
oft in die serbisch-orthodoxe denn die
russisch orthodoxe kirche dass keine
griechische und deutsche kirche gibt und
das ist überhaupt kein
ich bin dort ein volles kirchenmitglied
und wirke ganz normal als
kirchenmitglied aber sie verstehen es
dann nicht oder nein ich verstehe es
direkt verstehst natürlich nicht
dadurch dass ich dass die liturgie
gleich ist weiß ich eigentlich direkt
was gesagt wird und was im moment thema
ist sagt gottesdienst dauert drei
stunden oder ja nicht ganz also
zweieinhalb einschnitt vorbereitet immer
einer serbisch oder ochsen gottesdienste
in srf übertragen hat aus belp und zwar
im februar 2014
o
wir sehen wir den priester sie sind den
diakon nehme ich an
im allerheiligsten unter der sogenannten
ikonostase hinter diesen bildern ist das
so eine welt für sich da diese priester
wissen sie ja eine welt für sich
insgesamt die orthodoxe liturgie ist nur
nicht eine welt für sich sondern ich
würde sagen es ist ein aufbrechen der
welt was will ich damit sagen
die orthodoxe theologie und der kirche
versteht ihre liturgie als einen
besonderen moment im zeitraum konnten
jung wenn ich das so sagen darf ist
etwas sehr sinnliches schmecken des
bruders ja genau also auf jeden fall
also sehr sinnlich und ein aufbrechen
von von zeit und raum das ist sehr
wichtig also es vereint sich in einem
nullpunkt könnte ich sagen die
vergangenheit die gegenwart und die
zukunft himmel und erde und das ist den
orthodoxen christen die einen
gottesdienst besuchen bewusst
sie sehen zb die heiligen rundherum in
der kirche die abgebildet werden
das soll das genau symbolisieren sind ja
eigentlich wenn man so sieht tod von der
vergangenheit tote lehrer und
lehrerinnen die als beispiel in der
vergangenheit gewirkt haben aber im
glauben der orthodoxen kirche sind diese
personen real auch präsent in diesem
gottesdienst so viel tradition
mitschwingt gibt es priesterinnen nein
priesterinnen beziehungsweise das
priesteramt für frauen kennt die
orthodoxe kirche nicht
es ist einerseits kulturell auch sehr
stark veranlagt dass besonders im osten
europas natürlich die frau noch eine
eine sehr starke rolle hat aber dem
geistlichen amt nicht zugelassen wird
gibt es darüber eine diskussion sie
haben die diaspora tabellensituation
gesellschaftlich ganz anders gibt es
darüber eine diskussion vielleicht sogar
auf das motto
nein über die frauenordination wird
nicht diskutiert weil ich muss ihnen
ganz klar sagen es gibt in der
orthodoxen kirche keine nennenswerte
strömungen diesbezüglich wissen sie so
was muss von unten kommen und und im
moment gibt es keine strömung die das
verlangt sowohl von seiten der frauen
nicht als auch der männer
wenn es irgendwann mal das verlangen
geben sollte und eine starke strömung
müsse sich die kirche sino dahl über
dieses thema äußern und sich auch damit
beschäftigen
aber ich glaube dadurch dass es im
moment ja kein bedarf gibt keine
innerkirchlichen bedarf darüber zu reden
ist es natürlich auch kein thema auf der
porsche boxster innovation werden auf
dem paradoxen konzil
es klingt schon sehr bewahrend erstaunt
sie das persönlich das ist da gar keine
bewegung gibt
gut ich habe es ja erwähnt ich bin im
westen aufgewachsen und ich kenne
natürlich vom bild her
dieses vom ja dieses bild eine
priesterin jain von der bayerischen oder
kirchen obwohl ja am besten auch nicht
jede kirche durch das priesteramt für
frauen zugelassen also die römisch
katholische kirche unterbreiten
es ist er also wie ich gesagt habe
bisweilen der boxen kirche fremd auch
von der tradition heraus frauen zum
priesteramt zuzulassen gibt es darüber
eine diskussion wird sich auch aber es
wird sich glaub ich auch in den nächsten
jahren da nicht ändern nichts ändern
diesbezüglich da bin ich mir relativ
sicher in der römisch katholischen
kirche gibt es natürlich eine diskussion
auch bewegungen
es gab eine synode die sich über mehrere
jahre erstreckt hat in der
römisch-katholischen kirche zu
familienthemen da waren heiße eisen
sollen menschen die gläubige geschieden
sind und wieder geheiratet haben zum
union zugelassen werde
und wie soll man in der kirche mit
homosexuellen menschen sind das themen
die diskutiert werden
insgesamt natürlich das sind also auf
die region ziehen
auf dem konzil war das mal in einem in
einer vorbereitung
des papieres war es mal thema besonders
über gleichgeschlechtliche beziehungen
zu sprechen und so weiter das wurde dann
gestrichen
bei einer bearbeitung der texte
man spricht hier nur von minderheiten
insgesamt und ich verstehe es schon so
dass dort dies auch mit einwirken soll
das man minder minderheit nicht
diskriminieren soll das sagen die texte
diesbezüglich muss ich sagen also sie
haben erwähnt also dass in der römisch
katholischen kirche eine diskussion war
über die zulassung zur kommunion und
geschiedenen ehepaaren in der orthodoxen
kirche ist es natürlich so dass man bis
zu drei mal heiraten darf also einmal
ist perfekt
aber dann also das sogenannte economia
prinzip also dass man über dem norma das
gesetz nun über schauen darf und kann
weil der mensch ja nicht und helfer ist
sie könnte dann dreimal auch in der
kirche heiliger als ist dreimal möglich
kirchlich zu heiraten in der orthodoxen
kirche wäre es praktiziert ja also das
so für die fahren die zurückbleiben nein
nicht unbedingt sondern es ist es hat
sich gezeigt dass doch manche menschen
mit dem ersten mal nicht ihren
geeigneten lebenspartner gefunden haben
für beide für genaues genau und deshalb
hat dann die orthodoxe kirche eigentlich
sehr sehr früh schon gesagt dass man
hier zum menschen zugehen muss und ihnen
auch erlauben muss ihr leben dann so zu
gestalten dass mit sie glücklich werden
und das haben sie eine erklärung für
diese offenheit jetzt wissen sie ich
habe sehr oft gehört also eine
verwunderung gegenüber der boxen kirche
wenn es manche punkte geht um eine
offenheit natürlich haben sie ein bild
wie viele der zuschauenden keine
geschlossenen kirche was hot dogs kirche
angeht also ich selbst hat als orthodox
er würde sogar sagen die orthodoxe
kirche ist sehr sehr offen
in sehr vielen themen zum beispiel ich
hab's erwähnt was die wieder
verheiratung angeht und insgesamt wissen
sie es gibt das gesetz in der orthodoxen
kirche den omas und manche rächten sich
auch sehr streng an dem gesetz aber
dieses economia prinzip dass sowohl auch
index
kirche existiert in der orthodoxen
kirche ist ein sehr schönes eine sehr
schöne tradition der boxen kirche die
sagt ja wir haben unsere gesetze und das
ist auch gut wenn man sich daran erhalt
hält aber der mensch wie gesagt ist
nicht unfehlbar
und deshalb kann man manchmal man könnte
es auf deutsch so ausdrücken ein auge zu
drücken
hier aber auch da gibt es verschiedene
strömungen immer jeden fall natürlich
und es ist auch wissen sie wenn es keine
verschiedene strömungen gebe in der
kirche
ich habe erwähnt die hotdogs kirchen der
stadt üblich auch gezeigt die orthodoxe
kirche ist eine weltkirche und es gibt
dort verschiedene kulturen verschiedene
einflüsse und es ist ganz logisch dass
es verschiedene strömungen gibt und es
auch logisch dass ich verschiedene
regionale kirchen streiten über
verschiedene themen gibt das dokument
patriarchat und andere kirchen sind
etwas offener zu manchen themen
besonders die slawischen kirchen etwas
geschlossen
sie haben es angesprochen über
gleichgeschlechtliche paare und so
weiter denn es ist sind auch
verschiedene kulturen hinten dran
da gibt's ja ganz rigide stellungnahmen
und er ist meiner homosexualität als hin
zur homophobie also wirklich
hassattacken wissen sie hass attacken
gibt es natürlich regional gibt es hass
attacken diesbezüglich aber ich muss
ihnen sagen wenn ich als orthodoxe
theologe und die orthodoxe theologie
näher betrachtet natürlich ist die
homosexualität boxen kirche nicht
erlaubt aber andererseits werden diese
menschen auch nicht von der kirche
verstoßen
also sie sind teil der kirche sie leben
in der kirche und sie sie wirken genauso
wie alle anderen in der kirche sie
werden nicht aus der kirche
ich sag's mal herausgeschmissen
beziehungsweise getrennt sondern ihr ihn
wird zugesprochen dass sie sozusagen
auch für ihr seelenheil in der kirche
kämpfen sollen wir alle anderen auch
aber ich habe berichte gelesen von
jugendlichen in der schweiz die zur
fertig auto drucksen tradition gehören
die einfach sagen es geht nicht ich kann
mich nicht erhalten ich kann nicht sagen
dass ich schwul bin ich würde von der
familie verstoßen in haft verurteilt von
der kirche ja ich habe ihn ja schon
gesagt es gibt regionale unterschiede
die er auf das kulturelle basieren als
auch das theologische der mensch ist ein
erschaffung gottes und wir haben alle
unsere unser pathos wenn ich das so
sagen darf und unsere verlangen
und manchmal auch unsere übertretungen
gegenüber dem kirchlichen gesetz oder
dem pastoral umgesetzt und der theologie
hier ist aber die kirche sehr sehr offen
wissen sie es gibt in der orthodoxen
kirche die so genannte metanoia also den
weg zu bereuen
hier ist alles inbegriffen ich beziehe
es jetzt nicht nur auf die
gleichgeschlechtlichen beziehungen und
so weiter sondern insgesamt auf alle auf
das gesamte menschliche verlangen etwas
zu tun und die kirche sollte aufrufen
sich in der kirche sozusagen so wie man
ist ja zu vollenden wie wir in der boxen
kirche gern sagt sich zu vergleichen
also gott ähnlich zu werden
und das hier und dort jeder seine eigene
art hat das muss jedem zugesprochen
werden und ich glaube diskriminierungen
jeglicher art sind zu verurteilen
besonders von der kirche die eine einen
offenen offen sein muss eigentlich für
jeden menschen auf dieser welt also ich
höre da ihre sehr offene haltung heraus
gleichwohl dass eine große spannung oder
für menschen wie sie es eben die
diaspora nennen also die aus russland
aus verschiedenen ländern kommen
in dieser tradition vielleicht die
eltern aufgewachsen sieht dann die
jugendlichen hier aufpassen
das ist schon ein riesenthema oder ja
auf jeden fall also ein sehr wichtiges
dokument das verabschiedet werden soll
auf der synode betrifft auch alles nicht
dass ökumene dokument dass es gibt es
natürlich auch sehr wichtig aber für
mich besonders pastoral für die diaspora
es sehr wichtig die entscheidung über
die eheschließung hier gibt die
verabschiedet werden soll das sozusagen
orthodoxe christen andere christen auch
kirchlich auch kirchlich dass sie mit
kirchlich heiraten dürfen bisweilen ist
es so dass viele orthodoxen ländern die
meisten oder kirchen dies zulassen
aber wenn man das eigentliche gesetz
nimmt also enorm was wäre es nicht
möglich das feld sozusagen economia
prinzip dass ich vorhin erwähnt habe ich
glaube eine entscheidung diesbezüglich
wäre besonders für die die us-bürger
auto dobson weltweit sehr sehr wichtig
dass wir eine große entlastung um das ja
gesagt dass sie demnächst heiraten
werden
also es wäre für sie gar nicht möglich
eine frau die nicht in der orthodoxen
partition beheimatet ist zu heiraten
wie gesagt also schon also im moment ist
das schon möglich denn das ökonomische
prinzip lässt einen sehr großen
spielraum und eigentlich werden im
moment besonders in den diaspora alle
orthodoxen christen oder christinnen die
ein lebenspartner der lebenspartnerin
von einer anderen christlichen
konfessionen heiraten möchten werden in
einer orthodoxen kirche getraut
wenn sie heiraten können sie später noch
besser werden das ist so dass die
orthodoxe kirche ja also den
verheirateten priester kennen und es ist
nur so dass man vorher heiraten muss
bevor man priester wird also nach einer
feier ist dass das die möglichkeit noch
mal zu heiraten nicht mehr möglich wird
gern noch eine frage zum schluss
ansprechen es gab dieses historische
treffen von bachs franziskus mit dem
russisch-orthodoxen papa dem ersten auf
kuba februar was diesen jahres wohin
steuern diese beiden kirchen die römisch
katholische und die orthodoxe
geht es dann richtung fusion ich würde
nicht von fusion sprechen
wissen sie es war ein sehr großes
ereignis auch in den medien dieses
treffen obwohl natürlich der dialog der
römisch katholischen kirche mit der
boxen kirche nicht seit gruber
angefangen hat sondern schon seit
patriarch athenagoras die lange meer
hinaus also schon in den 60er jahren vom
ökumenischen patriarchat besonders
gefördert worden ist und russland hier
natürlich durch die politische und
kulturelle lage sehr lang nicht an
diesem dialog
ich sag jetzt mal auf höchster ebene auf
die materialien ebene beteiligt war
das treffen war ein erster kontakt
zwischen der russischen welt- und der
westlichen welt auf jeden fall ich habe
die vermutung dass hier besonders auch
die flüchtlingsströme nach europa und
insgesamt die lage im nahen osten also
die verfolgung der christen und
christinnen im nahen osten die sehr sehr
stark ist und besonders auch über
deutsche christen betrifft doch kiril
also material tiere dazu bewegt hat sich
mit dem papier papst franziskus zu
treffen um solche themen eventuell auch
gemeinsam anzugehen
ich würde sagen es ist keine kirchen
fusion das jetzt auf jeden fall in den
nächsten jahren nicht geben
aber es ist eine zusammenarbeit und die
gemeinsame interessen besonders was die
christen im christen im nahen osten
angeht ist
erlauben sie mir vielleicht weil sie
kehren angesprochen haben ich war ja
auch ganz kurz ja wissen sie ich glaube
dass das große problem des konzils der
orthodoxen kirche ist 1 wir haben leider
in den letzten jahrzehnten in der
orthodoxen kirche einen sehr starken
piscopo centris muss also auf die
bischöfe garantiert mund wo das
kirchenvolks sozusagen kirchlich gesehen
leider etwas außen steht
ich glaube diese ideologisierung des
bischofs und ich spreche hier exakt von
einer ideologisierung weil ich glaube
die kirche muss immer ein organ sein
klerus und volk und er wollten sie hier
von diesem konzil einen
richtungsweisenden entscheiden
diesbezüglich muss sagen leider nicht
und aber ich erwarte dass das kirchen
volk wissen sie egal was dieses konzils
scheitert in der orthodoxen kirche kann
er hat gab es ja schon sehr viele
konzilien die entscheidung getroffen hat
aber die letzte bestätigung und das ist
das positive kommt vom kirchen volk also
erst wenn es rezipiert wird und vom
kirchen volk bestätigt wird kann es
eigentlich auch erst gesetzte kirche
werden und deshalb ist auch in diesem
fall die letzte instanz dass kirchen
volk und das erfreue ich mich natürlich
sehr
ganz herzlichen dank für diese einblicke
für dieses gespräch
vielen dank für die einladung mit
rockenden münchen aus einem orthodoxen
kloster in griechenland geht es hier
weiter
dabei steht die musik für ästhetik und
protest gegen gesellschaftliche
missstände
sehen sie selbst